I consider myself a man of decent logic
and who has a fairly firm grasp on the
perceptions of reality a man whose
down-to-earth and lives in the realms of
the real world until today when that
reality was challenged by a blue printed
hedgehog and it's flying box with two
tails this is the gateway to madness
that the world of children's programming
has chosen to call The Adventures of
Sonic the Hedgehog imagine coming across
a mentally disabled person who's not
only criminally insane but was also
drunk high and a whole frontal lobotomy
leaving little to no intelligence left
in his brain he would be normal compared
to the Adventures of Sonic the Hedgehog
so what's wrong with this show what's
right with this show that's the shorter
answer it's actually hard to come up
with words to describe how affection
crazy this show is it is that crazy so
rather than talk about it let's go ahead
and try and watch it the key word being
try so here's the opening of the show
which I suppose is supposed to sum up
what the show is about look you're
talking sonic we got Sonic Sonic
sonnig a psychotic technolon exonic well
that explained everything so the show
takes place and who gives a shit land I
call bet because clearly you look at the
backgrounds knowing the creator's just
throw up their arms and shouting really
who gives a shit
civilization boy I thought we'd never
find civilization where what you mean
those couple of building blocks in the
distance that's supposed to be a city oh
yeah one of the great architectural
designs of cinema Gotham City the castle
of Gondor shitty ass bricks I can't wait
to see more now I know you might be
thinking are you just showing the
opening of this show again nope this is
literally all the show is just chasing
and yelling it's like a cartoon for kids
to enter X intro so the show stars sonic
duh fresh from his hip video game off
the Sega Genesis he's voiced by none
other than Jaleel White that's right
berkel from family matters I see you
oh yeah cuz herbals voice was such a
delight to listen to wasn't it Oh care
about in this part is the safety of the
keys I shall be forced to burn away
castigate you in front of your peers
he's accompanied by his sidekick tails
little fox who can fly around because he
was born with two tails makes sense to
me they're out to stop the evil robotic
who seems to live in a house designed by
frank lloyd wrong his evil plan is to
you guessed it take over the world
no I'm gonna do it I'm taking that joke
you know it's funny at first but now
it's just getting annoying
so you are never gonna hear that joke
again of course it's gonna take more
than that to stop of course fucking joke
so Robotnik isn't really as much a
dictator as much as a comic foil for
Sonic but what do you expect when you
dress like Santa Claus and
sadomasochistic GIMP brother Ronnie
troublemaking teenager has made me tear
every half from my beautiful head Wow
he hates him so much that he actually
tad to the word hate right on his very
teeth that's a lot hate he tries to stop
him by building robot they're designed
to kill and destroy these machines are
so lame I doubt they'd make it as
half-baked Megaman villains two of the
robots created or robotic chicken named
scratch and whatever the hell this is
named grounder and if you thought
Sonic's voice was annoying just listen
to this ear sodomy hey fast rap young
man I give you just shoot oh how do I
describe the voices of these two you
ever tell your side of a story where
you're trying to make the other person
you're talking about sounds really
obnoxious so I'm sitting there just talk
to my friends when suddenly the teacher
walks is like what are you doing here
aren't you supposed to be in class he
made me
sister he made you too dumb to quit and
then my idiot friend is like dude I
dunno I thought it started later yeah
the chase is over cap you make them
sound annoying for a reason that I oh
there's also a monkey named coconuts who
wants to catch a sonic on his own often
declaring war on a speeding bullet a jog
I took on a rock with season on Hedgehog
I don't know why but this vengeful war
hungry monkey always reminded me of
george w bush maybe it's the cowboy hat
he's got weapons of mass acceleration
the way silac always gets out of their
traps is by running of course and
putting out several disguises as the bad
guys never seem to realize there's a lot
of blue over dress hedgehogs in the
neighborhood recently don't crowd the
hood admission is free well that came
out of nowhere I love how he actually
wins to the audience to point out that
him under that costume because he's such
a master of disguise that we've really
needed the extra I'm over there how does
that work I don't care how stupid you
are if you just say I'm over there
nobody's gonna go he's over there even a
mentally ill aren't that stupid look at
this animation by the way there is no
thought focus or structure put into any
of it this is an animation it's fuckin
doodling I don't wanna watch something
that's less entertaining than what I
draw on my desk in high school guess you
guys won't be staying for a second show
you got that right so the whole show
pretty much is just the evil robots
trying to set up traps to catch Sonic
and how the traps always seem to
backfire gee does that sound familiar at
all
unlike the roadrunner though this show
has the misfortune of having people
speak obviously a very big mistake come
on here comes the Hedgehog get ready to
bow baboon oh I thought you had him
Oh God how much Jerry had a plot
compared to this is you probably Gavin
this show has absolutely no basis and
logical reason but there are just really
some things that go beyond the
boundaries of comprehension like watch
this scene as they try to set up yet
another track what pumpkin pumpkin what
what what pumpkin what I don't care what
drug-induced land you're in you cannot
blow in your hand and come up with a
pumpkin how did you even come to that
conclusion I mean what's next he's gonna
blow in his hand and the beautiful
woman's gonna come out Wow how can you
blow into your hand and make a woman why
would you even be chasing hedgehogs if
you can pull into your hands and make a
woman it does not add up my god okay we
can advertise a show like this I mean
what did the commercials look like hey
kids
rinse didn't be making too much sense
for you then put on The Adventures of
Sonic the Hedgehog you'll love this
cosmic out of body raping of your senses
it's like a Japanese show in English
only you still have no idea what's going
on you must be at least this high to
watch one of the running jokes I guess
is that Sonic Oates has a thing for
chili dogs
yeah we a long way from the nearest
chili dog stand two chili dogs to go can
we find some more chili dogs who doesn't
chili dogs it might still I
by chili dogs from bad guy you know this
with other cartoons there's some sort of
rhyme or reason Bugs Bunny with carrots
Winnie the Pooh and honey a blue
hedgehog and chili dogs what's the
connection
my guess is it's what gives him his
supersonic speed that's to say I'm sure
he's fast fast feet but nothing can
breathe fire like a gas producing bean
product that makes you want to ship more
than a Metamucil cocktail gotta roll
Charles even in the realm of its own
insanity it doesn't make any sense when
look at this scene where they're trapped
in a cage as a trapdoor slowly opening
up first of all tails can fly why
doesn't just pick up sonic and let them
off the ground second are you seriously
telling me that you can't fit through
those bars you can drive a fucking
pickup truck through those giant gaps
don't you realize the terrible villain
is about to destroy this entire place
nope don't pay no never mind
decorative itch maybe you should
consider a career in politics come on I
think pretty pebble commercial funnier
than this torture this is madness solder
and just when you think you've seen the
lame as part of the show
Sonic actually has a moral to teach at
the end because I really want a blue
hedgehog who eats chili dogs to be my
children's teacher we're surrounded
Sonic Pony Man 1 no way tails this is
nothing not one one is for really
merchants that's right kids don't go and
I won't like you're being attacked by
people who want to kill or connect you
only Club for important things like if
the cable goes out and you can't watch
The Adventures of Sonic the Hedgehog
satellite it's important but even the
messages are weird I mean there's the
usual stuff like learn to share and eat
your veggies but some of these are just
strange believe it or not every year
some ignorant kid takes a ride in a
clothes dryer just like this one
if you think it's smart to climb in a
dryer you're really all wet really kids
climbing the dryers is such a national
problem they have to devote the entire
end of an episode to that in Noland
given the intelligence of the people who
watch this show this is probably a good
thing to teach because my guess is when
they're not trying to operate heavy
machinery with their budget the
I'm trying to do something stupid like
this I mean what else could you possibly
take that would be as stupid as that
even you can learn something from a
sloth it's crazy
another possible meaning of the word
nothing about this dumb except it's pure
bullshit it's the kind of move they
would show Malcolm McDowell the
Clockwork Orange to break his mind now
if you can believe it there was actually
another show about stomach that came out
the exact same time they even got the
same actor Julia White to play the lead
because one sonic show wasn't enough to
piss us off I guess the show is called
Sonic the Hedgehog but later got the
name Sonic said am why because it came
on Saturday mornings I guess it wasn't
that kind of stupid
isn't that like calling the title of a
show Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Eastern Standard Time look I know it's
customary to release a show after some
time has gone by but within that same
fucking year
that's a crazy answer right to the
bullshit I have put up with today well
forget it I give up
I don't even want to think about the
idea of this show procreating there's no
way in hell that any show connected to
this character can possibly be good I am
done done done
Johnny he can remove
he's the fastest thing
he is the fastest
you
yeah
I mean talk about the complete opposite
this show takes a relatively bright
plotless video game story and turns into
a dark edgy and actually kind of epic
show it's setting with stylish its plot
lines developed its character
surprisingly complex but surely you
can't take something as silly look as
Robotnik and make him the least bit
intimidating
Jesus and evil Robotnik is cool if I can
make me one of the coolest villains ever
just listen to that kick-ass voice oh
that's good
that's very good indeed it's like he's
orgasming on everywhere he says I think
a nice touch well well well this is good
oh that's good that's very good oh wait
oh wait
Lola Lola Lola oh that's justice yeah it
was two cockles of man
okay the less I know about your cockles
the better still this was a pretty nasty
bad guy certainly a lot different from
that other show the story is actually
invented too unlike the other show or
Robotnik's trying to take over the world
in this show
he pretty much already has everything
was roboticized the city the animals
everything and it's just Sonic and a
secret group of freedom fighters who
tried to stop this industrial takeover
and bring the green back to the forest
wait wait wait wait I can't comprehend
this an environmental message that's
subtle
yes a barely there is subtlety in
Masonic cartoons unlike that other show
sanics not alone in his panel though he
has a team of animals that are kind of
like the Care Bears Ewoks and Smurfs all
rolled into one if you gave them weapons
you got tails of course but thankfully
he's kind of downplays the other
characters are Antoine a cowardly
Frenchman I anything to be such a young
well you say such a weary one but this
terrible lazy he's not so good for our
hands up we go yes in fact why do we
just serve it cuz I talk we French know
how to do right surrender make love and
be unbelievably snooty
now where's my French beret accordion
twirly moustache a striped shirt a Jerry
Lewis a half animal half machine named
bunny rabbit yeah I know I hate the pun
too and the big ugly ol wolf says a
better to see all with my dear that wolf
is nasty her bunny next day is a
one-eyed snake sugar oh yeah I had a
one-eyed snake come after me too bad my
vagina eats people what would it being
roboticized at all and last but not
least princess Sally the face that
launched a thousand furries what's a
furry you may ask um long touchy story
let's just say my Space Jam review when
I said there weren't people out there
who wanted to fuck bunnies I was wrong
oh okay that's a harsh generalization
but for what I can tell is people who
are fascinated by half animal half human
creatures but for some reason centaurs
are never on there what's up with that
what do you got I guess the centaurs huh
are you ant I said tight ha ha I don't
know but either way I found out this
character has kind of a cult following
but here's my question if she's a
princess where's the king they talk
about sometimes but they mostly hint at
the fact they is probably dead so
shouldn't she be in charge now I know
he's alive I just don't know where
you're not really a princess you just
took the title because it sounds cute
take some authority you're a queen Queen
it up bitch they don't all have to look
like Elizabeth the second you can still
be pretty but start moving forward and
take some responsibility the breeze will
respect you for it this is a really cool
looking world - it's been a gritty in
heart with more threatening robotic
opinions unlike that's all
so in fact these settings are so
detailed like you think if they stumbled
onto a Star Wars movie half the time the
force is with you but you are not a Jedi
yet but perhaps the biggest upset for
most people is the last episode not
because it was so bad but because it was
too good Robotnik creates a doomsday
device half the freedom fighters that
capture Sonic and Sally discovers some
sort of ultimate power they destroy the
device wipe out the city Robotnik
retreats forever is warming side kick it
escapes in a pod Sonic and Sally confess
their love for each other and they all
live happily ever after
or do they live don't celebrate too soon
Hedgehog its might
holy shit what is that oh my god I can't
wait for the next episode what the
hell's gonna happen why is it video game
spin-offs never learn leaving us on a
cliffhanger doesn't guarantee a sequel
it just pisses us off anybody do have a
sequel it doesn't always me it's gonna
be good just be self contained
oh well that being said this really was
a great show in fact it's actually
better than I remember it
maybe I should have put it somewhere on
the top of living anime and nostalgic TV
shows just considered a number 12 spot I
guess it literally took nothing and turn
it into something I'm like that on our
fucking show thanks I think eternity
time I spend nothing in fact you know
what it's like it's like two students
who turn in two separate projects for a
class hey there teach here's my project
I tried to add as much character and
psychological development as possible
given the guidelines but I think I came
up with a pro environmental show that
will actually make kids enjoy the force
without you know shoving it in their
faces
well this is very well-put-together
strong story good character working
beyond the material given to you a plus
now where's my other student fuck up
McDonough ass
hey teachers my project and it's awesome
it's got a lot of running a lot of a
chili dog hahahaha it's got a monkey and
a chicken and then just yell all the
time around blah blah blah blah blah
blah it's totally awesome
mcdhh um as did you put any effort into
this no I just got hi I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't have
to
you